preguntarlo en primer lugar cómo
interpreta ustedes de las acciones de
pyonyang
yo creo que con estas manifestaciones
que se habla de este lanzamiento pero
lleva varios lanzamientos de misiles
incluso se afirma que algunos
hipersónico en las últimas semanas pero
singularmente este este arma este cual
son 17 lo que ha venido a poner de
manifiesto es que esta esta arma
independientemente de la carga que
llegara algo que se desconoce y que
pueda o no llevarla los intereses que se
ha lanzado a una altura suficiente como
para poder calcular que se han andado
horizontalmente podría llegar
perfectamente a cualquier parte de
estados unidos
otra cosa que tenga la capacidad de
poder llevar ojivas nucleares porque
este tipo de arma lo que hace es salir
fuera de la atmósfera y luego
reintegrarse y el reintegro podría ser
complicado producto verdad es que por
los monitores japoneses sabemos que la
prueba 62 cayó muy cerca de alguna isla
principal del norte de japón y la verdad
es que es muy preocupante porque este
tipo de armamento en un país como este
en manos de un dictador puede causar un
estrago verdaderamente notable
ahora porque quiere usted que corea del
norte elige precisamente este momento no
en medio de la guerra en ucrania para
lanzar este tipo de misiles y advertir a
eeuu sobre una eventual respuesta
corea del norte lanza este misil y dice
que ha sido como un mensaje rotundo y
claro frente a las sanciones que
directamente sobre el personal y sobre
los programas de armamento nuclear que
ha puesto en marcha eeuu y otros países
esto es la argumentación que utiliza a
pyongyang kim jong-un para servir a
través este alarde belicoso por cierto
en una puesta en escena absolutamente
terrible recordando casi la película de
matriz aunque él un poco entradito en
carne por lo tanto estamos ante un
sujeto volverse absolutamente un
dictador uso atrapar que puede causar
peligro entidad él se presente en este
momento de conflicto como una potencia
nuclear policía nuclear que todavía
tiene que confirmarse iguales son
verdaderamente sus capacidades pero que
el mundo contempla con bastante temor
un país en el que por cierto tres de
cuatro de cada cuatro personas viven de
la ayuda humanitaria internacional esto
es lo que tenemos que estar contemplando
en el mundo a esto es a lo que se
enfrenta el mundo
nos queda poco tiempo pero no quiero
dejar de preguntarle lo siguiente no
hablábamos de la guerra en curso en
ucrania y con todas las miradas
internacionales no concentradas allí
creo que podemos esperar más pruebas o
acciones de este tipo en corea del norte
es muy posible es muy posible el de sant
posicionamientos en las últimas semanas
y es muy posible que de producirse una
intensificación de las sanciones corea
del norte vuelva a hacer algún alarde
bélico para demostrar cierto músculo
militar josé maría gil garré muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24